bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité ce soir les grands chefs
rebelles tchadiens de retour à n'djamena
après des années d'exil timan erdimi et
mahamat nouri ont été accueillis par une
foule compacte
ils doivent participer au grand dialogue
national inclusif censé déboucher sur
des élections et le transfert du pouvoir
aux civils plusieurs fois reportée il
doit débuter ce samedi
des scènes de désolation en algérie
après des incendies qui ont fait au
moins 38 morts les banquiers continuent
de lutter contre 24 feux de forêt dans
le nord et l'extrême est du pays des
centaines de familles ont dû fuir leur
logement
l'angola passe au défi de la réforme de
son modèle économique à moins d'une
semaine des élections générales
l'économie est la principale
préoccupation des électeurs même si
quelques améliorations ont été observées
l'inflation atteint 25% et le chômage ne
cesse d'augmenter reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux à suivre dans ce
journal
c'est peut-être un tournant dans
l'histoire du tchad les grandes figures
de la rébellion timan erdimi et mahamat
nouri sont arrivés ce jeudi à n'djamena
les deux hommes ainsi que des dizaines
de membres de groupes politico
militaires doivent participer au grand
dialogue national inclusif il débutera
samedi et doit ouvrir la voie à de
prochaines élections près d'un an et
demi après la mort de débit père mamadou
jim t by est sur place pour france 24
une foule immense des proches et
sympathisants a pris d'assaut très tôt
ce matin l'aéroport international hassan
djamous ce djamena pour accueillir deux
importants chefs rebelles tout le 2
rentre au pays après des années d'exil
d'abord timan erdimi chape de l'union
des forces de la résistance ufr arrivé
lui très tôt dans la journée suivie
trois heures plus tard par le général
mahamat nouri chef de l'union des forces
pour la démocratie et le développement
rdd
visiblement très ému de retrouver ses
proches et amis
à cet instant la joie de me retrouver
avec mes parents et mes amis
tchèques et j'oublie tout le monde je
n'ai pas grand chose à dire c'est pas
grave
les deux rebelles chefs des mouvements
les plus importants et historiques sont
signataires de l'accord de paix de doha
ils ont saisi la main tendue par les
autorités tchadiennes ils sont rentrés
pour participer au dialogue national
inclusif et souverain qui doit s'ouvrir
dans deux jours à djamila tous le deux
entendent participer à la reconstruction
du théâtre ce sont deux figures
importantes ici pour rappel les deux
chefs rebelles timan erdimi neveu du
maréchal idriss déby de faire marcher
idriss deby et le général maman nourrit
en 5000 de défense de débit ont conduit
une colonne armés qui étaient arrivés
aux portes d'un djamena avant d'être
réponse et en février 2008
deux jeunes guinéens de 17 et 19 ans tué
par balle mercredi lors d'une journée de
contestation contre les militaires au
pouvoir
des dizaines de personnes ont affronté à
coups de pierres les policiers les
gendarmes dans la banlieue de conakry le
point avec notre correspondant un malik
diabaté
les parents de ibrahima baldé dit c'est
ton et de alpha roumat bariz saison sont
encore sous le choc
les deux adolescents ont été tués par
balles mercredi au cours des
manifestations dont les quartiers de
wanidara et de bambeto en haute banlieue
de conakry le parent que nous avons
rencontré ce matin sont inconsolables
on m'arrêtait avec la maison ici c'est
vers 15h30 il a réussi là-bas une balle
au niveau de l'abdomen et les on voulait
le transporteur laplink mais
malheureusement kolélas il a reçu l'aval
au niveau de l'abdomen il a rendu l'âme
en cours de route réclame d'asus est
malade ou cityville parce que vous savez
en guinée et a eu beaucoup de morts
jusqu'à présent n'y a pas de justice
mais crédit dont le pays de nombreux
blessés et des dizaines
d'interpellations ont été enregistrés
notamment dans la haute banlieue de
conakry ainsi que dans plusieurs villes
du pays
face à ce regain de violence les appels
au calme se multiplient
s'ils ne sont pas ensemble si nous ne
pouvons pas vivre ensemble si nous ne
pouvons pas se pardonner s'il ne pouvons
pas accepter le même mot comme le même
pays notre pays ça va être difficile que
nous avançons en guinée depuis jean le
dialogue est rompu entre les militaires
au pouvoir la classe politique et la
société civile
le médiateur de la cedeao thomas boni
yayi l'ancien président béninois est
attendu à conakry dimanche pour engager
des pourparlers entre les différentes
parties
voilà pour les précisions de malick dia
quitter la france se sort de son silence
après l' escalade verbale des autorités
maliennes bamako accusant notamment
paris de soutenir les terroristes
islamistes le porte parole du ministère
français des affaires étrangères
condamne la multiplication des
manipulations de l'information
l'ambassade de france au mali indique
dans un tweet que la france n'a
évidemment jamais soutenu directement ou
indirectement ces groupes terroristes
qui demeurent ses ennemis désignés sur
l'ensemble de la planète
une marche contre la force barkan
interdite au niger elle devait avoir
lieu hier était organisée par le
mouvement m 62 qui rassemble des
organisations de la société civile ses
organisateurs ont lancé une pétition
pour exiger le départ des militaires
français et précision d'aral girard
depuis niamey un mouvement qui tient des
positions très dures à l'égard de la
présence militaire française
ici au niger une présence souhaitée par
le gouvernement en place et validé par
un vote de confiance cet été par
l'assemblée nationale du pays mais que
les membres du m 62 considère comme
illégale ses membres du m 62 avait prévu
une manifestation dans niamey ce
mercredi pour contester le renforcement
de l'opération barkan sur le sol
nigérien mais aussi contre la cherté de
la vie et l'augmentation du prix du
gasoil une manifestation qui a
finalement été interdite par les
autorités moins de 48 heures avant sa
tenue prévue les raisons évoquées
trouble à l'ordre public possible mais
aussi risque d'infiltration par des
assaillants criminels ou encore
terroristes pour abdoulaye sèye du
coordinateur du m 62 et la méthode
française n'est pas la bonne il rejette
le renforcement de cette opération et
donc l'augmentation du nombre de soldats
au sol de l'opération barkan prévu sur
le sol nigérien nous estimons que la
présence de forces étrangères
après 60 ans d'indépendance anoeta n'est
pas un bon signe parce que nous états
doivent assurer la souveraineté y
compris du point de vue sécuritaire
c'est à dire 12 que nous emmener
national de matériel adéquat comme ils
sont en train de le faire un micro
former nos fds comme ils sont en train
de le faire indique m après
l'interdiction de leurs manifestations
les membres du m 62 ont prévu une marche
pour la dignité le 18 septembre prochain
avec les mêmes objectifs
la pire catastrophe humanitaire au monde
c'est le cri d'alarmé lancé par le
directeur général de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé pour sa région
natale le tigre et il estime que les six
millions de personnes vivent dans cette
région en guerre avec le gouvernement
éthiopien subissent une cruauté
inimaginable et suggère que le racisme
pur et expliqué que la situation
s'éternise dans l'indifférence on écoute
je peux vous dire que la crise
humanitaire au tigré est bien pire qu'en
ukraine et je dis cela sans exagérer et
comme je le dis il ya plusieurs mois
déjà peut-être que la raison de tout
cela est la couleur de peau des gens du
tigré da skin of the people insights et
d'un émoi depuis longtemps en fait je
n'ai entendu aucun chef d'état par les
la situation du tigre et surtout en
occident pourquoi je pense que nous le
savons tous
il s'agit du pire désastre sur la
planète je suis originaire du tigré mais
ce n'est pas pour cette raison que je
dis tout ça
c'est la vérité date de tous
des mots forts auxquels a répondu addis
abeba le porte-parole du premier
ministre éthiopien bill and say you may
a qualifié ces déclarations de contraire
à l'éthique et juge le docteur tedros
indigne de son poste
après la tragédie des incendies en
kabylie à l'été dernier le nord et
l'extrême est de l'algérie sont en proie
aux flammes au moins 38 personnes ont
perdu la vie dont 11 enfants des
dizaines de milliers d'hectares sont en
partie en fumée le pays ne dispose plus
depuis plusieurs années d'avions
bombardiers d'eau récit de sophie la
mode
une tornade de feu qui n'a rien épargné
sur son passage laissant des centaines
d'hectares de forêts détruits et des
dizaines de morts même ses moutons et
été brûlé vif dans les provinces d'al
tarifs et de sétif
je ne comprends pas comment c'est arrivé
c'était comme une tornade
j'ai aidé les enfants à s'enfuir je ne
pouvais rien faire à cause de tout ce
qui se passait dehors vous pouvez voir
ma maison le garage a été détruit je
n'ai rien pu sauver mais dieu merci les
enfants sont chassés
des hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau ont
été déployés dans trois zones du
nord-est du pays avec le soutien de
l'armée pourtant certains accusé les
autorités d'être mal préparée avec trop
peu de capacités aériennes disponible
malgré le nombre record de victimes dans
les incendies de l'année dernière où 90
personnes ont été tuées et cent mille
hectares détruits l'algérie a déployé un
avion russe qui est tombé en panne et
l'union européenne a envoyé deux avions
canadair en renfort la semaine dernière
les autorités algériennes ont aussi
exprimé des doutes sur l'origine de ces
feux c'est peut être lié au climat mais
pas que on mène une enquête pour
connaître les raisons précises de ces
incendies
il ya une vraie question qui se pose
plusieurs feux se sont déclenchés en
même temps à souk ahras
et jijel et celle enquête qui pourra
nous éclairer
une enquête qui a porté ses fruits trois
personnes ont été arrêtées ce jeudi en
lien avec les incendies
une transition en douceur au kenya c'est
en tout cas ce que promet le chef de
l'état sortant ou kenyatta il ne s'est
en revanche pas encore exprimé
publiquement concernant la victoire
annoncée lundi de son vice président
william ruto uru kenyatta avait apporté
son soutien à raila odinga qui prévoit
de contester les résultats de ce scrutin
en justice
à quoi ressembleront elle les visages
des futurs députés du parlement
sénégalais de nouvelles têtes dont
beaucoup sont inconnus du grand public
mon faire leur entrée à l'assemblée
nationale le 14 septembre prochain le
camp présidentiel arrivé de justesse en
tête du scrutin gardera la majorité
absolue avec 82 sièges alors que la
coalition de l'opposition
iwuy askanwi en a obtenu 80 nos
reporters elimane dao et sam brad pitt
sont allés à la rencontre de ces
nouveaux membres de l'hémicycle
il est même des nouveaux visages de la
scène politique sénégalaise papa
dubrulle fans est entrée en politique il
ya juste quatre mois ce journaliste de
36 ans leader de la coalition les
serviteurs fait sa première sortie
publique devant les médias depuis son
élection en tant que nouveau député à
l'assemblée nationale il compte proposer
des lois une fois au parlement pour
favoriser notamment l'emploi des jeunes
ces jeunes la recherche la fenêtre de
tir ils sont aujourd'hui à travers le
désert pour rejoindre un eldorado entre
guillemets nous voulons aujourd'hui
redonner espoir à cette jeunesse-là
année à l'assemblée nationale une
position libre transparente et logique
qui permet aujourd'hui de dire à ces
jeunes là que vous n'avez pas le droit
de perdre espoir oumar sy aussi partie
des nouveaux visages de l'assemblée
nationale ce spécialiste de l'aviation
civile a bénéficié malgré lui de
l'élimination par le conseil
constitutionnel avant les législatives
de la liste principale de la coalition
d'opposition ya eu askanwi inscrit à
tête de liste des suppléants il a été
élu député un état totalement méconnu du
grand public ce que nous avons connu
jusqu'à présent en tout cas avec la
majorité présidentielle
c'est des députés qui ont qu'il y est
urbi orbi qu'il sont les députés du
président de la république nous nous
sentons investi d'une mission du peuple
et par conséquent notre seule ambition
c'est de travailler au service exclusif
des populations
la coalition au pouvoir ben barka a
obtenu de justesse la majorité au
parlement une situation inédite au
sénégal pour cet analyste politique les
électeurs ont voulu de nous voler la
classe politique les sénégalais ont
rejeté une certaine manière de faire ça
même peut-être connaître l'identité des
députés ils ont voté pour la rupture
donc cette structure doit être vue doit
être visible au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale les nouveaux députés
sénégalais vaut prendre leurs fonctions
le 14 septembre ce sera la quatorzième
législature de l'histoire du sénégal
mercredi prochain les angolais se
rendront aux urnes pour élire leurs
députés et leur président après cinq
années de récession due à la baisse des
cours du pétrole et à la pandémie de
kobe de 19 le pays a renoué avec la
croissance en 2021 mais le miracle
promis par le président joão lawrence
est loin d'être devenu une réalité
l'économie peine à se diversifier le
chômage atteint des records reportage à
luanda de nos envoyés spéciaux clément
boudreau et juliette du bois
il y a cinq ans pramod à sidya a fait
l'un des plus gros pari de sa carrière
ce propriétaire de plusieurs boutiques
et resteront à luanda a investi 75 mille
dollars dans tout cas la première
start-up de livraison à domicile en
angola
pouce à son comptoir
aujourd'hui la plateforme est un succès
avec 1000 commandes par jour et des
franchises dans plusieurs pays de la
sous région acting problème doit de
démarrer petronio ici en dehors des
diamants et du pétrole il y encore
beaucoup de secteurs dans lesquels on
peut investir si vous avez une idée qui
n'a pas encore été lancés ici et qui
marche bien ailleurs il y a du potentiel
pour créer une entreprise
un potentiel encore loin d'être
exploités l'économie angolaise est à la
traîne malgré d'importantes réformes
comme la libéralisation de sa monnaie et
l'assainissement des finances publiques
après cinq années de récession la
croissance a repris en 2021 mais
l'inflation atteint 25% et le taux de
chômage est passé de 24 à 30 % azango en
périphérie de luanda christina est sans
emploi depuis mars
depuis que j'ai perdu mon emploi c'est
difficile de payer le loyer de payer les
frais de scolarité des enfants de payer
l'électricité
c'est vraiment compliqué parce qu'il n'y
a que mon mari qui travaille et son
salaire ne suffit pas pour tout payer
par exemple nous n'avons toujours pas
payé le loyer en 2017 le président joint
au lawrence ho s'était pourtant présenté
comme l'homme du miracle économique
promettant de diversifier l'économie et
de créer cinq cent mille emplois la
crise liée à la pandémie est certes
passée par là mais pour cet économiste
le mal est plus profond
l'angola est l'un des vingt pierre
environnement d'affaires du monde nous
n'avons pas d'infrastructures nous avons
des mauvais service d'éducation donc
tant que l'état ne s'occupe pas de
résoudre ces problèmes tout en laissant
le secteur privé se charger du reste
nous n'arriverons pas à diversifier
l'économie
et quoi de mieux en angola le pétrole
représente encore 30% du pib et 90% des
revenus d'exportation
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]